bonjour fabien j'ai beau merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur arte france ce
matin vous êtes en ce moment en sicile
mais vous exercer à turin l'une des
villes concernées par ces élections dans
quel état d'esprit sont les turinois
alors c'est un peu particulier pour
turin puisque la maire sortante ne se
représente pas tu auras un quorum a été
les deux villes un petit peu
particulière puisque c'était le
mouvement 5 étoiles qui avait gagné la
dernière élection donc un nouveau
mouvement un nouveau parti un nouveau
style et là évidemment c'est aussi pour
eux le mouvement 5 étoiles voir s'il y a
la confirmation justement de leur
présence sur le territoire pour turin
justement la mère madame à peine dino ne
se représente pas donc la ville de turin
est totalement ouverte à un nouveau
président une nouvelle coalition il
grandes incertitudes autour de la ville
de turin actuellement le mouvement 5
étoiles dit antisystème la ligue
nationaliste de matteo salvini le parti
au pouvoir de centre gauche qui est
donné favori dans les sondages et qui
est le plus à perdre
là c'est très très difficile justement
de faire une évaluation réelle puisque
tous les partis ont quelques difficultés
si on reprend de la gauche et à droite
le parti démocrate était très très bas
il est revenu avec son nouveau
secrétaire et recoleta qui revenu ça va
mieux mais c'est pas encore on va dire
un parti qui a une grande bande un grand
dynamisme le mouvement cinq étoiles a
maintenant un président de parti donc il
restait les temps si ce système est
maintenant il rentre un peu plus dans le
système c'est l'ancien président du
conseil je sais des comptes et qui est
chef du mouvement 5 étoiles il est très
écrit aussi à l'intérieur parce qu'on
trouve que ça dénature le parti par
rapport à son origine donc le mouvement
5 étoiles à quelques difficultés si on
regarde le côté droit la ligue du nord
la ligue de matteo salvini à de sombres
affaires actuellement un des conseillers
de matteo salvini et
sont pas faire de trafic de drogue est
donc le parti est un peu entachée même
chose pour justement le parti qui est
leader actuellement à droite fratelli
d'italia de giorgia meloni qui a une
sombre affaire de tentative de pression
sur un journal donc nous avons on va
dire tous les partis politiques en
italie qui ont des difficultés
différentes selon la situation parfois
structurelles parfois on va dire plus
d'actualité ou de scandales mais dans
tous les cas c'est très difficile
aujourd'hui de faire une estimation de
qui pourrait gagner demain à l'élection
car oui aussi c'est très variable
surtout à droite où justement on pensait
que la ligue est elle assise très forte
de la droite finalement aujourd'hui le
parti fratelli d'italia semble vraiment
débordé dans la droite la ligue et
gagner de plus en plus de consensus
les experts évoquent un scrutin-test
pour mario draghi en quoi les élections
municipales peuvent elles changer la
donne
bien sûr c'est toujours une élection
municipale c'est par une élection
nationale il ya toujours l'aspect local
bien sûr qui compte un certain mr sont
vraiment très apprécié dans leur ville
donc on peut imaginer que les eaux de
l'ajustement de leur parti il gagne il
est évident pour mario draghi aussi que
c'est une manière puisqu'il est un peu
externe à tout cela il est arrivé
en italie après plusieurs années à
l'étranger il n'est pas encarté
directement dans un parti donc ce qui
sera intéressant pour mario draghi
aujourd'hui c'est de voir quels sont les
partis qui s'en sortent le mieux quelle
est la tendance actuelle car si dans
deux ans il ya de nouveau y aura dont
l'élection est peut-être que justement
mario draghi restera aux affaires car
certains le souhaitent on va dire c'est
un peu un sentiment général dans tous
les cas mais si mario draghi rester
après l'élection dans deux ans il faudra
tous les cas recomposée qu'un nouveau
format ça c'est sûr deux partis
politiques pour avoir une majorité et
donc pour mario draghi c'est très
important de regarder ce type d'élection
pour savoir avec qui il devra travailler
demain et selon les résultats d
législatives à nouveau c'est possible
on verra cela aussi les législatives
c'est un autre système il faut voir
aussi qu'il ya souvent un système
différent électoraux par exemple
aujourd'hui pour les élections
communales vous pouvez parfaitement et
en italien voter pour une liste mais
donner une préférence pour un autre
maire donc vous voyez vous avez aussi
une catégorie électoral qui est mixte et
donc même pour les législatives on peut
imaginer qu'il y ait d'autres formats
selon les régions et là aussi il ya une
grande inconnue autour de cela
mettrait je pense que ça va rester à peu
près dans le même ordre même si
législatives sont légèrement différentes
mais je pense que là on va voir quand
même un indice très très importants de
ce qu'il est le futur de l'italie ce
week end
mario draghi est à la tête du 67ème
gouvernement depuis l'après-guerre
comment expliquer cette instabilité
chronique politique en italie la durée
moyenne 1 du gouvernement en italie
c'est 3 184 jours depuis 1981 1944 de
plus selon le parisien et ses 530 deux
jours en france depuis
1958 comment les italiens vivent cette
instabilité chronique
bon déjà il faut quand même voir un peu
on va dire l'aspect positif si vous
regardez les gouvernements italiens du
début du xxème siècle surtout pendant la
période on va dire poste première guerre
mondiale les gouvernements ont une durée
de vie de trois semaines un mois 6 mois
donc on était vraiment dans des
situations beaucoup beaucoup plus basse
est encore plus instable aujourd'hui
bien sûr il ya encore un grand problème
de stabilité elle est due principalement
au fait que les coalitions sont très
dures être construite que les cris sont
régulièrement provoqué par par les
partis politiques directement pour
relancer justement et chercher un
nouveau président du conseil et puis les
lire ce qu'on appelle en italie levant
tony parker c'est à dire qu'il ya le
vote avec les tripes les personnes ont
une réactivité c'est pas toujours on va
dire comment dire c'est pas toujours
réfléchi 1 c'est assez instinctif ce qui
est aussi une qualité mais bien sûr ça
va porter parfois à des votes des
réactions
de la part des italiens un peu immédiate
un peu forte et qui peuvent parfois
pêché un peu en stabilité finalement
j'ai envie de vous dire que les italiens
sont un peu habitué à ce format est
finalement il ya un nouvel équilibre qui
se crée lors des dernières années c'est
à dire que vous avez une instabilité des
résultats politiques mais vous avez
généralement un président du conseil qui
externe c'était mario monti c'est
toujours du mario draghi c'est à dire
que nous les italiens choisissent plutôt
un président du conseil externes à ces
parties de manière à avoir comme un
arbitre au milieu des partis politiques
merci pour cette analyse et ce
décryptage fabien gilot je rappelle que
vous êtes enseignant à l'université de
turin en italie